ce qui frappe chez jean-marc oui c'était
un homme extrêmement endroit est
extrêmement attentif aux autres
au fond c'était vraiment quelqu'un qui
avait le sens du service public très
profondément mais c'est ramos le manque
d'emploi qui peut être un peu galvaudé
mais lui non c'était et s'était
profondément lui il avait commencé très
tôt dans les conseils de quartier aux
années 80 il avait été pendant trésorier
d'abord de du paris versailles puis
président depuis presque trente ans
depuis plus de trente ans mais quelques
mois puisqu'en temps et puis - si vous
voulez je lui avais connu jean marc
passe quand j'ai créé deux mois molière
c'était très vite devenu un pilier du
mois parce que c'était quelqu'un
d'extrêmement curieux et donc on le
connaissait comme sportif ancien
pratiquant l'athlétisme à haut niveau
quand il était jeune mais mais sa
curiosité aller dans tous les domaines
et il a aimé beaucoup la vie culturelle
il aimait énormément voyagé avec son
épouse donc voila c'était c'était
vraiment une belle personne comme on
aime rencontrer dans la vie